I only speak the truth what are things
you don't like about yourself what do
you think are your most obvious
character defects like probably I tend
to be pretty selfish because I was
raised mostly as an only child because
my half-sister was out of the house so
yeah and like being very needy and
possessive of our friends and people I'm
dating and those you still have those
character defects yeah oh yeah a lot of
my friends who have come a long way but
I definitely still feel them because
you've had squabbles with other
comedians have I not squabbles but but
you know okay
well they've just been like you've been
friends with a comedian and then there's
been a fight and then I don't I wouldn't
say that we were friends and there was a
fight I would say that there are people
that I don't get along with and try to
avoid like for a while you think like oh
because I do the same thing as this
person we have to all be friends and
hang out and then you mature and realize
like actually I don't like this person's
behavior so I'm just gonna not hang out
with them that's what maybe that yeah
you're right which i think is totally
fine and I don't think that means that
I'm bad or that person's bad or any of
those people are bad I just think it's
like oh well I'm not I don't know I like
people who are a little more humble and
little like less self-obsessed
even though I tend to be selfish I don't
think I'm self-obsessed
self-obsessed yeah I mean I know that
you know I could just name all right now
who doesn't like me right Vince Vaughn
yeah I know that I'm just throwing it
out there Christopher Titus I didn't do
anything the guy you just hates he
doesn't like me yeah isn't it kind of
empowering to just be able to say that
it almost makes them look stupid cuz
it's like why the [ __ ] don't you like
that like I don't know it's funny you
don't have to like me you know I don't
know anything I think that's a character
defect to to be kind of a people pleaser
and to always want to be yeah yeah that
is just the most unrealistic thing you
can ever ask and there are people who
constantly seek that yeah and all kind
of resolve themselves into who they
think that person will like
like it's a yeah those are the dangerous
types
I think people pleasers are probably one
of the most dangerous types of people
what's also just like I can't imagine
that that's anything but just being in a
prison where you're like yeah all right
you're at the whim of everyone around
you basically yeah you know what Mitzi
sure once told me mm-hmm
I swear to god she told me I just back
in the early like mid 90s I met Mitzi
and my friend Freddie Soto used to drive
a limo and he should drive mitzi around
Freddie Soto by the way anyone listening
is one of the funniest stand-ups I've
ever seen he passed away but he is one
of the funny looking like he said
specials he's one of the funniest guys
ever okay
by the way but Mitzi told me once she
goes you know you know what makes a star
I go what she goes you have to have half
the audience love you and have half the
audience hate you at the same time
that's crazy and I go and I thought
about that right so it's like if you try
to like get everyone to like you right
it's just like well there's only a
couple of stars in the world that have
that and they're enigma like Tom Hanks
I've never heard anyone go ahead guy
actually what force come I bet you there
are kids no probably our Jennifer
Lawrence everyone used to think she was
the apple of everyone's eye and I think
that you know even t-swift
you know they you look at somebody like
Roseanne Barr is divisive you know Jim
Carrey divisive like half people like
people hate used all the whole time
hated him from beginning to end
he's so broad that he fired him you know
may hate you know I think I think that
it's really good to have people not like
you and have enemies because you're
doing something I've had people call him
when I've done radio and said I just
think that you're awful well you won't
have it with me and Nick Youssef it was
unbelievable I was in Orlando
okay where the tragedy happened so let's
move aside but then what happened was
years ago oh here's another oh okay I
have to I thought
check it out
I was in Orlando at the improv and I
couldn't get the back door to open you
know to get to the green room so I had
to go around but as I'm going around
right I heard a lady like talk about
each poster that's on the wall that she
couldn't see me
me and Nick usov so she went to Gabriel
glasses photos I loved him right I just
want to hear what she said cuz I know
she was going down the line oh my god DL
Hughley he's the best then she got to
mind headshot right and she goes this
guy right here is the [ __ ] work this
lady and then and then Nick and I walk
so this you can see as she goes I'm so
sorry
when she saw me I just smiled because I
know that that's you know not a bad
thing but did you really smile were you
dying no I was I was complaining for
three hours I know you and then I was
but can I say this and I didn't know
this but when I was in Arlington
Virginia two weeks ago a lady came up to
me and she goes I used to go to Virginia
Tech you perform there and I go oh yeah
completely forgot I go when did I
perform there like two weeks before
chill some way speaking of colleges do
you perform ecologist oh no no I never
so the University of Chicago bless
Chicago for this basically put out a
statement to all parents of incoming
freshmen saying like look we're not
gonna coddle your children we're not
gonna do these um trigger warnings and
they're going to be exposed to some
things they're gonna be uncomfortable
with they don't agree with and that's
probably going to like you know shock
them but we're not gonna coddle them
anymore
isn't that [ __ ] great that people are
actually standing up to the fact that
like a bunch of these college kids are
just turning into geez god-awful [ __ ]
it's like that's why I like the one
wants to know how many comedians want to
perform at your colleges psychology used
to be the best thing in the 80s like
doing gonca no in the 70s and 80s like
people want to wear
ecologist because that was where you
would get open thinkers free but free
thinkers you know a lot of liberals
people with different ideas extreme
ideas sometimes and you'd perform and
but now it's so PC I did a show in what
was that New Hampshire or some some some
play like that and the next day they
wrote an article saying that Bobby Lee
perpetuates rape culture yeah I don't
have I don't have a scene of a single
rape rape joke in my act yeah and I
literally was livid and I said I call my
age I go that's it no more college I for
instance like now teachers are required
because you know like college professors
they're not safe unless they have tenure
right which they have to be in the game
for a certain amount of time but
previous to that they can get not they
can not get rehired they can get fired
they anything anything that they you
can't be a boat rocker in your early
years of teaching you cannot rock the
boat you can't you can't have a student
complain about you so for instance even
reading something like The Great Gatsby
the trigger warning is always you're
gonna be exposed to misogyny and the
idea of like I don't know like let's say
assault there has to be now college
students are demanding that there are
warnings before they read a book they
watch a movie before anything that
they're exposed to anything that they
could possibly dislike they want a
warning Wow
isn't that [ __ ] crazy so weird
especially like I was just in college I
don't know like seven years ago how is
it that different all of a sudden it is
very different so a lot of people like
some twenty mostly twenty eight year
olds don't even have have zero
relatability two kids or twenty four who
just got out of college like they can't
relate to those kids and it's only like
a four year gap because of the like just
a difference in culture and for instance
like George and I were talking about
like microaggressions they teach this in
college where a simple question like hey
like where are you from is now we're
supposed to take that offensively we're
supposed to take that as oh you're not
being racially or culturally sensitive
to me and what you're saying it's the
Liberals fault right it's not it is it
is
it's both it's it's no so everything is
to be taken as hostile under all their
auditory like here here's an example of
some micro aggression questions for you
guys when you say no subway I would stop
stop I want to tell you why no and we
talked about this a [ __ ] a mother no
no no no I'm gonna say this as I already
gave you the example right of me doing
an echo conference right and all the
religious schools walked out of my show
and the liberal school stayed okay
they're more open-minded
yeah they are they might accept the
accept gays no no sweetie you're you're
right because look they stand on the
right side of social justice but they're
in the wrong side of actual freedom of
speech they're they're on the right side
when it comes to gay rights and women
you know like wage gaps and things of
that sort but in terms of freedom of
speech you're not allowed to say [ __ ] if
you're a hyper liberal like you
everything offends you George is right
for instance this is one of them even if
you say if you say something like this
is a microaggression a perfect example
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I just get really
OCD about that type of stuff that's you
being insensitive to someone possibly
having a mental illness and they can
they can report you for a micrograph
that's just insanity that's afraid
that's unheard of that I'm so ADHD about
this oh wow Esther that's that's I've
never heard but see the thing is baby
I've never heard of that thing professor
there's a professor from like North
Carolina who actually created this a
list of microaggressions that we're
supposed to take as hostile and
derogatory so a lot of these kids are
now thinking they're victims of these
aggressions sort of it so I don't know
if that's so crazy I mean all I feel
like I can do about that is just
continue to be me and if someone does
accuse me of that I just be like you're
that's the way you feel then this
conversation today that's why I have to
it's like it's like
to mommy but ideology as to gotcha
[Music]